[Music]
help of southern nevada celebrated
50 years of helping the less fortunate
in our community during the pandemic
while many businesses closed the
non-profit had an influx of people
needing assistance
as many of their clients are a paycheck
or major event away from homelessness
people who had never heard about help of
southern nevada were reaching out
and that need for help they expect will
continue for years to come
our staff our boots on the ground our
crisis teams
our intensive case managers they were
the ones that were bombarded especially
our mobile crisis teams
where their typical job is being on the
streets
and encampments and tunnels looking for
people that are homeless and need
services
their job just kind of tripled
if you will and so i i have to give it
to our staff our staff was amazing
during this
pandemic help of southern nevada's come
up with a unique way to raise funds for
their clients these personalized boxes
as gifts for mother's day they cost a
hundred dollars fifty dollars from
every box goes back to a mom who needs
assistance
if you're shipping out of state you must
place your order by tomorrow
for all delivery orders within nevada
they must be made through april 29th
email events at help sonv.org
for more information